voici l'épicentre de la pandémie au
québec en ce moment les mauvaises
nouvelles s'accumulent dans la région de
la capitale nationale et le moral est au
plus bas
ça prend juste une personne ça prend une
entreprise générale est une honte
affectés sur mon doigt pays
ce restaurateur ne voit pas le jour où
il pourra rouvrir dans ma tête c'est
minimum jusqu'au mont joli challenge
mais je pense même pas ouvrir avant sont
le premier ministre annonce déjà que les
mesures d'urgence spéciales seront
prolongées jusqu'au 18 avril
inclusivement à québec gatineau et dans
chaudière appalaches chaud ce jusque là
que ça contient on monte et on a
actuellement à faire un invariant qui
plus contagieux
plus vicieux que jamais il faut être
plus prudent que jamais je comprends
tout le monde et annuel à 436 quand été
recensés ces dernières 24 heures dans la
capitale nationale
un sommet depuis le début de la pandémie
et il ya eu ce qu'on appelle un
événement super propagateur notamment
celui du gym c'est personnes se
retrouvent dans leur communauté dans
leur milieu
aux déboires du méga fitness gym
s'ajoutent nouvel événement la santé
publique a procédé à la fermeture de
concessionnaires automobiles à la suite
d'une éclosion responsable d'au moins 12
corps à mesure mon voyage
non je ne le savais pas du tout du tout
mais il serait du tir
il aurait vraiment du jean pendant ce
temps la situation reste stable à
montréal comme à laval
le gouvernement choisit néanmoins d'y
ramener dès dimanche le couvre-feu à 20
heures montréal puis laval c'est très
dense
ça veut dire que ça commence à exploser
l'aca pourrait rapidement créer des gros
problèmes dans nos hôpitaux
bien des experts jugent inévitable une
dégradation de la situation dans la
métropole
je pense que ce n'est qu'une question de
temps faut se rappeler lors de la
deuxième vague à l'automne
ça avait commencé par des régions qui
n'avaient pas été très touchés lors de
la première vague
alors moi je pense pour assister au même
phénomène chaud pour vous dire que je
comprends les québécois
critiqué de toutes parts pour ses
décisions contradictoires des dernières
semaines
le premier ministre a voulu remettre les
pendules à l'heure en bout de ligne
c'est nous c'est moi le qui va décider
donc ce que je dis par là c'est que je
m'assume ce quelqu'un pas content au
québec
d'ailleurs une personne à blâmer c'est
moins le gouvernement est inquiet et les
nouvelles projections d'hospitalisation
n'ont rien de rassurant
70% des patients admis en soins
intensifs ont maintenant moins de 70 ans
et à l'extérieur de la grande région de
montréal lyne esprit voit que les
capacités hospitalières dédié à la coved
pourrait être atteinte d'ici trois
semaines ici hugo lavallée radio canada
québec